Hallo Deutschschule.
Lange Deutsche Wörter.
der Universitätsprofessor.
Der Professor an einer Universität
ist der Universitätsprofessor.
Der Universitätsprofessor hält
eine Vorlesung an der Universität.
Studierst du auch an einer Universität?
Die Orangenlimonade.
Wasser mit Zucker und Orangennennt man Orangenlimonade.
Im Sommer trinke ich gerneeine eiskalte Orangenlimonade.
Die Schreibtischlampe.
Die Lampe auf einemSchreibtisch nennt man Schreibtischlampe.
Wenn ich abends am Computer sitze, braucheich eine Schreibtischlampe.
Der Fahrradsattel.
Der Fahrradsattel bei einemFahrrad muss weich und bequem sein.
Mit meinem neuen Fahrradsattelkann ich stundenlang Fahrradfahren.
Hast du auch einen bequemen Fahrradsattel?
Der Süßigkeitenautomat
In einem Süßigkeitenautomatengibt es viele leckere Süßigkeiten.
Es gibt so viele leckere Süßigkeiten!
Was soll ich bloß nehmen?
Isst du auch gerne Süßigkeiten?
Das Geburtstagsgeschenk.
Ich freue mich schon so sehrauf mein Geburtstagsgeschenk!
Boah, geil! Ein neuer Basketball.Ich freue mich riesig! Danke!
Der Gitarrenspieler.
Der Gitarrenspieler spielt Gitarre.
In jeder Band gibt es mindestens
einen Gitarrenspieler.
Spielst du auch ein Instrument?
Der Rasierapparat
Der Rasierapparat heißt auch Rasierer.
Der Rasierer
Ich rasiere mich jeden Morgen mit
meinem elektrischen Rasierapparat.
Die Waschmaschine.
Die Waschmaschine wäscht die Wäsche.
Oh nein! Die Waschmaschine ist kaputt.
Jetzt muss ich “von Hand” waschen.
“Von Hand waschen” sagt man, wenn man nicht mit der Waschmaschine wäscht.
Wäscht du auch manchmal “von Hand”?
Der Taschenrechner
Im Mathematikunterricht benötigt
man einen Taschenrechner.
In der Mathematikvorlesung an der Uni
haben alle Studenten einen Taschenrechner.
Der Gabelstaplerfahrer.
Wenn ich einen Gabelstapler fahre,dann bin ich ein Gabelstaplerfahrer.
Mein neuer Job als Gabelstaplerfahrerist richtig cool!
Das Kreditkartenlesegerät
Bitte halten Sie ihre Kreditkarte
an das Kreditkartenlesegerät.
Das Kreditkartenlesegerät liest meine
Kreditkarte und ich kann kontaktlos bezahlen.
Zahlst du im Supermarkt mit
Bargeld oder mit der Kreditkarte?
Die Werkzeugkiste
Die Kiste für dasWerkzeug nennt man Werkzeugkiste.
In meiner Werkzeugkiste habe ich einenHammer und einen Schraubenschlüssel.
Hast du auch eine Werkzeugkiste?
Die Straßenlaterne
Auf den Straßen in Deutschland gibt es viele Straßenlaternen.
Das gelbe Licht der Straßenlaternen ist inder Nacht so romantisch.
Der Fallschirmspringer
Der Fallschirmspringer springt mit
einem Fallschirm aus dem Flugzeug.
Als Fallschirmspringer hat man
wirklich eine wunderbare Aussicht.
Würdest du auch einen Fallschirmsprung machen?
Der Schminkspiegel
Wenn man zum Schminken einen Spiegelbenutzt, dann sagt man dazu Schminkspiegel.
Wenn man keinen Schminkspiegel hat, kannman auch die Smartphonekamera benutzen.
Achtung!
Jetzt kommt das längste deutsche Wort:
Donaudampfschifffahrtselektrizitätenhauptbetriebswerkbauunterbeamtengesellschaft
Und was bedeutet das jetzt?
Die Donau ist ein deutscher Fluss.
Ein Dampfschiff ist ein
Schiff, das Dampf produziert.
In einem Elektrizitätenhauptbetriebswerk
wird Strom produziert.
Aber was ist eine Bauunterbeamtengesellschaft?
Hm, egal!
Abonniere den Kanal der Hallo Deutschschule
und aktiviere das kleine Glöckchen.
Gib uns jetzt einen Daumen nach oben
und klicke auf diese Playlist für
weitere Videos zum
Deutsch lernen.